2006 national mall das alles
zerberstende alten endlich ist der kurs
wieder da
jetzt geht es um folgendes ich hab da
einen abprall an dich wie dieser york
dienstag
also
man schlicht riese nach dieser brauch
dich nasentropfen dir doch in wahrheit
lässt sich zu weit aus dem fenster
madita was wir noch vor seinem text mit
zum zopf oder so ist muss es existieren
wie der ps4 etr zum schluss dass es mit
kann man in zukunft auch mitglieder
hatten sie täten studios der kleine a
tree style ist zwar nicht gut da war was
mach ich da
ja erstmal probst und ich will dein wrap
style ich weiß jetzt nicht von wem du
dich inspirieren lassen hast aber auf
jeden fall ein geiler raps soja
macht da sowie verwalter deine frage war
wann schlägst du lars wir haben gestern
lhasa ordentlich auf die fresse gegeben
bei audi saß wo auch christoph von
klicks um dabei war und l bewegung wird
wir haben im dreierteam lars ordentlich
auf die fresse gegeben das muss erst mal
reichen
was war zweite frage selfmade records
neue mitglieder wer weiß vielleicht ist
das schon was im busch ich will nicht zu
viel verraten jetzt
aber seid gespannt freunde vielleicht
kommt der nächste